hi there steve kaufman here
um today i was going to answer more of
these questions that i received
as part of our sort of competition what
question would you like to ask steve if
you have 30 minute conversation
and i was going over some of them and i
will go over some of them
but it dawned on me that there's a
certain common theme
throughout
you know the answers that i want to give
and so really the subject of my little
chat today is the importance of passive
vocabulary
um
in all of the languages that i have
learned
uh you know if i if i look for sort of a
measurement of how i'm doing if i look
for a goal
you know other than the fact that i like
to read things that are interesting and
listen to things that are interesting
my goal is to increase my passive
vocabulary
and
i firmly believe that the larger your
passive vocabulary the greater your
potential in the language and so that
the simplest
measure of where you are in a language
is how many words you
know or understand even
just in context
now
right away there are people who say you
know that our known word counted link is
not accurate
because
you know
we measure each form of the word as a
different word that's true so there's no
scientific value i can't go bragging
that i know
90 000 words in russian when in fact in
terms of word families it might only be
30 000 and then there are people who say
there aren't that many words in the
dictionary and they it doesn't matter
none of that matters the only thing that
matters is that i am motivated to
increase my known word count increase my
passive vocabulary
and
i think that to me if i look at some of
the questions here you know
uh how can i um what
what is the effective way to learn a
bunch of languages do a lot of listening
and reading and increase your passive
vocabulary you can't
be in a position to speak them every day
all of them if you're learning a number
of languages but if you have a large
passive vocabulary in a number of
languages when you do get that
opportunity
you can take advantage and you can
develop your speaking quite quickly i
have had the experience many times when
i build up my passive vocabulary beyond
a certain point and especially if i
combine listening and reading there are
phrases and words in my brain when i
start to speak it's difficult but very
quickly i start to be able to use these
words i activate my passive vocabulary
and remember the native speaker always
has a much larger active vocabulary than
you the learner therefore you need to be
able to understand what people are
saying
so
you know the answer is how do i motivate
myself how about you set yourself some
goals of where you want to get to in
terms your in terms of your passive
vocabulary your your known words count
on link or whatever so that you can pick
up a book and you can watch a movie and
you can understand the language because
if you do those things
when the opportunity to speak arrives
and eventually as i say all the time we
need to speak a lot
you will have the weapons you'll have
the tools you'll be able to manage
so you know uh
how to be motivated seems to be a common
theme okay you have to be motivated by
the interest but you can also again set
yourself this target of increasing your
passive vocabulary question what was
your catalyst for starting to learn
languages
i just got interested in french then i
was sent to learn chinese and since then
i once you realize that you can learn
languages that is something that you can
do
and that you can then discover a new
world like i happen to see something on
twitter that was written in arabic i
don't know the words but i can make out
the sounds more or less because the
arabic writing system is kind of more or
less and so far as how it's it's
pronounced
so the motivation it feeds on itself but
here again if you're on your first
language
dra and you aren't yet able to consume
interesting
to you content or you can't understand
movies or
then drive that passive vocabulary word
count
uh
you know for example if i want to call
it
which audiobook should i start with well
that depends entirely on your interest i
can't possibly answer that question
uh how to select material again you have
to scan you have to search the internet
you can for example if you're looking
for as i did and say ukrainian or
romanian i simply in google translate if
i can't yet say ebook on ukrainian
history i'll put it in english get it in
ukrainian or romania and put it into
google
and up come some sites and then i choose
something that i want and i download it
and use it but that's secondary so you
there are these different ways if you
are genuinely motivated you will find
ways to select material of interest you
will find the content that you want the
audiobooks the radio programs you have
to be motivated to do it the motivation
comes from your interest but
as a sort of measurable
milestones that you target
work on your passive vocabulary that's
my advice
uh and and people sort of
i think in traditional language
instruction they're too concerned about
what you're able to say it doesn't
matter what you're able to say at the
beginning if you can introduce yourself
or if you know the names of uncle
cousin nephew or whatever they teach and
then the different colors and stuff
which you're going to forget anyway
it doesn't much matter what you're able
to say at the beginning what matters is
are you eventually going to be able to
engage with the language in a meaningful
way and in order to do that you have to
have a large passive vocabulary so
my advice and in a way my answer to a
lot of these questions is focus on your
passive vocabulary
thank you for listening and i look
forward to your comments
[Music]
you